we are going to do a full review today
of CPAC 2023 the conservative political
action conference happening in
Washington DC Under The Cloud of uh
sexual assault charges against its
organizer Matt schlapp now Donald Trump
closed out the speech on Saturday
delivering what I believe is his most
dangerous and unhinged speech yet
closing out what is not only a
deplorable conference but a conference
that really gave me confidence that
Donald Trump is still in control of the
loudest wing of the Republican party and
he is the candidate to beat in the 2024
Republican primary after everything
that's happened after everything we've
been through his presidency losing in
2020 spending years claiming it was
rigged announcing he's running 2024 all
of it Trump showed up and gave one of
the scariest and most delusional
authoritarian speeches that he has ever
given and that is saying a lot because
he's given what hundreds thousands of
these speeches impossible to fact check
hundreds of Lies why Trump swollen we
never know his right eye almost
completely swollen shut going a nearly
two castro-like hours in length a couple
of glitches it wasn't the glitchiest
speech but Trump stumbling once again
with United States crazy the racist
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
who is presiding over one of the most
dangerous and violent cities in the
United States the United States and
Trump continuing to struggle with States
later calling them Spates
and I'll challenge the governors of all
50 states that's right if you are
currently governing any of the states
Trump is coming for you one other funny
moment before we get into the scary part
the speech briefly interrupted by
someone playing really loud music and
then protesters started to boot our
country I'm sorry the his Trump's fans
started to boo the guy playing the loud
music for that love our country have
been so great on that issue and the
Pervert to use the names of Washington
and Lincoln to buy millions of dollars
in ads to say bad liveless and incorrect
things about us
so Trump yelling over the music and the
people uh yelling at the music guy
thank you
all right so a couple funny moments but
then it got very scary and very
dishonest just a sampling of Lies Donald
Trump said that while he was President
he finished some Wars which I I couldn't
I'm not aware of trump ending any wars
the only president in modern history who
did not have
any new Wars no new Wars I finished some
ogles
uh fact Checkers unable to find any wars
that Donald Trump finished a big theme
of the speech Trump going hard at
Republicans of course going after the
leftist Marxist communist socialists of
course but going very aggressively
against Republicans signaling this is
going to be a disgustingly chippy and
dirty primary here is Trump calling out
Mitch McConnell and you know we all want
to see success but it's far more
important to them than it is to us
because of that location we are never
going to
be a country ruled by entrenched
political dynasties in both parties
rotten special interests china-loving
politicians of which there are many
you're listening to this Mitch McConnell
are you listening
and the crowd liking the Civil War
Friendly Fire
[Applause]
[Music]
frightened of telling the truth or is
truly evil and bad I don't know yeah
Trump doesn't know Trump then spending
more time going after Jeb Bush and Karl
Rove and Paul Ryan a lot of Friendly
Fire here when we started this journey a
journey like there has never been before
there's never been anything like this
we had a Republican party that was ruled
by Freaks neocons
globalists open border zealots
and fools
but we are never going back to the party
of Paul Ryan Karl Rove and Jeb Bush
and Trump is honest in the sense that if
he is going to have a shot the
Republican party can't go back to Paul
Ryan Karl Rove in Jeb Bush because if
they did Trump trump would be out on his
ass quite frankly Donald Trump seemed to
suggest that he really believed many of
the people who back in 2020 told him
listen you're going to be back in the
Oval Office in six weeks less
used to say four years a lot of people
said well sir
the election was so bad you'll be in in
one year a lot of people in this room
you'll be back in six weeks sir
but it's a bad system in many ways very
yeah it's a system that doesn't have a
process for reinstating a president
after someone else has been president
for six weeks that's what Trump is
bemoaning there we've got a bad process
you know people came to me sir they said
they were crying they said sir you'll be
back in five weeks Biden so bad and then
our system wouldn't allow it Trump found
out that's right we don't have a system
we have a line of succession that goes
from the president to the vice president
to the Secretary of State and then on
down uh uh it doesn't act the speaker of
the house it doesn't actually go to the
guy who lost the last election that is
true that is not the system that we have
Trump then talking about the wall and
this is the moment at which Trump's
sanity was most questioned Trump seems
to say that they hid the wall Biden took
the border wall with Mexico and he hit
it some wear so that it wouldn't be used
the wall was sitting there waiting to be
installed the easiest part
Arizona couldn't use it Texas and
Arizona said could we
use that wall we'll finish it right up
and they said no and they actually took
it away and they hid it they put it in a
hiding area which of course was revealed
pretty quickly all you have to do is
send a couple of helicopters up that's
right but they wouldn't let him use it
under my leadership what on Earth is
this guy talking about they hid the wall
they moved the wall and hid it but then
with some helicopters Trump figured out
where Biden hid his border wall that
this is delusional stuff I can't think
of a charitable interpretation of what
on Earth Trump is talking about then
Trump using really strange language
talked about baby bonuses now there is
actually a policy connection here let me
first play for you the deranged Insanity
that Trump said but then I want to say
more about it challenge the governors of
all 50 states all 50 states to join me
in a great beautification campaign we
will rename our schools and boulevards
not after Communists but after Great
American Patriots right
we will get rid of bad and ugly
buildings and return to the Magnificent
classical style of Western Civilization
wow
we will support Baby Boomers and we will
support baby bonuses
for a new baby boom how does that sound
that sounds pretty I want a baby boom
so what's interesting about this is on
the one hand it's very reminiscent of
Hitler's mother's cross which was a
program to encourage Germans to have
kids but on the other hand there's this
thing called the child tax credit which
Joe Biden and Democrats would like to
make permanent a higher tax credit for
children which in a way is kind of what
Trump is talking about although the the
child tax credit isn't to encourage
people to have children it's to provide
financial support for those who do but
Republicans are against making that
permanent so it's all just a weird
mishmash sort of a verbal uh inkblot
test of sorts Trump also taking shots
not only at Republicans but at Fox News
during this deranged speech which by the
way carried the speech not too good and
we actually have to say this
I hope Fox doesn't turn off but we did
much better in 2020 than we did in 2016.
right
I mean you didn't
but we have no choice not in the sense
that you lost anyway Donald Trump again
Reviving this idea of sending people
addicted to drugs and who just are
homeless to tent cities sort of like
camps of sorts remember they would
always accuse Barack Obama he's going to
send you to a camp Trump quite literally
is saying that's what he wants to do
take a listen
oh no
looks like this particular clip may be
glitching
let's see if I if I can fix that for my
audience here
I do believe that I can I have
confidence that I can here we go
leadership we will take the homeless
drug addicted and severely deranged get
them off our streets and create 10
cities where we will get them the help
they so desperately need right
and the crowd reacting pretty positively
to that
Trump also uh wrongly claiming by the
way that so-called foreign mental
institutions and quote insane asylums
are being emptied into the United States
that's not happening by the way they're
emptying out their prisons and you've
heard me say that but they're also
emptying out their mental institutions
and what uh to use a strong couple of
words insane asylum insane asylum that's
where anybody see Silence of the Lamb
that's where they come from Silence of
the Lamb uh has been emptied Anthony hop
basically undocumented immigrant
versions of Anthony Hopkins are just
being released into the country none of
that is going on just so people know
Trump at one point asks whether anyone
has watched TV everybody you ever see
television you know it used to be
we'd build our military we were proud of
it would be doing all things would be
all you see on thing investigation
investigation investigation now with
that being said
you got to look at Hunter I mean how
crooked is that deal but right no and
often going back to the topic of Hunter
Biden and then Donald Trump talking
about uh with really really strange
language how he is the retribution he is
now talking about retribution and
revenge this was maybe the most
dictatorial moment of the speech other
than like 40 other moments that were
almost as dictatorial in 2016 I declared
I am your voice today I add I am your
Warrior I am your Justice and for those
who have been wronged and betrayed
I am your retribution I am your
retribution I don't even think Trump
knows what he's talking about he wrote
something people told him but it's
really really scary dystopian stuff
Trump at one point on a very strange
word salad about
um oil and gas and electric vehicles we
have oil and gas but we don't want the
but we want everything including
electric cars but we also want gasoline
because the cars go longer oh and they
are preferred by many people
pretty Crystal Clear position huh
we don't like quick drives that have
stopped for two and a half hours
yep Trump is not pleased with the range
of electric vehicles and then Trump
bringing out the L word lynching saying
that they are looking to Lynch him
of course he is the ultimate victim as
many of you know
and unfortunately another very glitchy
clip here I don't know what is causing
these glitches uh and I hate to ever be
unprepared for my audience uh but a
couple a couple of glitchy Clips here
let's continue
what the hell did you get me into yeah
[Applause]
his words grand jury I didn't know that
they want to Lynch you for doing nothing
wrong I didn't know they want to Lynch
you for doing a great job I didn't know
they want to put you away because your
poll numbers are better than anybody
they've seen in years yeah Trump's best
poll numbers so a few thoughts about
this speech obviously Trump telling
hundreds of Lies delusional dangerous
authoritarian one notable thing from
Trump's very long speech is that while
he did attack Paul Ryan and Mitch
McConnell and Karl Rove and Jeb Bush and
rhinos he didn't overtly go after any of
the 2024 Republican contenders or
would-be contenders like the santis he
didn't even allude to DeSantis in this
particular speech that's interesting and
unclear what the strategy there is Trump
did make claims that CPAC was packed
Trump's speech was the most full of any
of the events and it was only about 85
percent full many of the other events
very much empty and then another thing
is the crowd really didn't seem that
energized NBC News uses Benjamin goggin
tweeted a picture and said as Trump's
speech bleeds over to the one hour mark
a notable number of people they're
filtering out Matt Gates slipped out
early shaking hands in the aisle energy
tonight is much sleepier than last
year's Trump CPAC speech I am
increasingly convinced that Donald Trump
as the Republican nominee is the best
thing for Democrats particularly after
seeing the this speech I will talk more
about that tomorrow let's now move on to
a few other things as many of my viewers
and listeners of course know I have many
family members who work in the field of
mental health and I think one of the
most important things that we can do is
to both increase access and reduce
stigma when it comes to Mental Health
Services and that's why I am thrilled
that one of our sponsors today is better
help better help is the world's largest
therapy service and it is 100 online
with better help you can tap into a
network of over 25 thousand licensed and
experienced therapists an important word
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues you answer a few
questions about your needs and your
preferences and better help will match
you with a therapist that meets your
needs you can then talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
could be text could be chat phone video
call you can message your therapist
anytime you can schedule live sessions
when it's convenient and if your
therapist isn't the right fit for any
reason you can switch to a new therapist
at no additional charge with better help
you get the same professionalism and
quality you expect from in-office
therapy but it's on your schedule
and it's at a more affordable price get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Pacman the link is down
below